Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK
Alice: 我误打误撞竟然发现了切皮蛋的妙招
Alice: I accidentally discovered a trick to cut century eggs
Alice: 那就是把它冷冻起来
Alice: You just freeze them
Alice: 好的不是妙招切不动
Alice: Actually, it's not a trick, you can't even cut them
Alice: 比我的命都硬
Alice: It's harder than my life
Katrina:  但是他不会乱溜
Katrina: But it doesn't slip around
Katrina:  你知道我现在看你干所有的事情
Katrina: You know, watching you do everything now
Katrina:  都觉得很神奇
Katrina: Feels so amazing
Katrina:  因为我妈也不会做
Katrina: Because my mom can't do it either
Katrina:  这种我从来没见过
Katrina: I've never seen this before
Katrina:  有种非常崇拜的感觉
Katrina: I feel a sense of admiration
Tasha: 把他们搅合到完全融合的状态
Tasha: Mix them until they're fully blended
Tasha: 就是你既看不出来他像他
Tasha: So you can't tell them apart anymore
Tasha: 你看他现
Tasha: You see now
Tasha: 在就是还有油花在那个最边边
Tasha: There's still oil on the edges
Tasha: 嗯所以就还没有融合
Tasha: So they haven't blended yet
Tasha: 差不多就可以了吧
Tasha: It should be fine now
Tasha: 可以再搅一下
Tasha: You can mix it again
Tasha: 我去拿下一个材料
Tasha: I'll get the next ingredient
Lucia: 哈哈哈可以
Tasha: Hahaha, okay
Tasha: 然后再放上去就可以
Tasha: Then put it on top and it's done
Tasha: 40克好像
Tasha: 40 grams, I think
Tasha: 我没记错的话40克
Tasha: If I remember correctly, 40 grams
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice: OK
Tasha: 然后你可以搅一搅它
Tasha: Then you can mix it
Lucia: 再搅一搅
Lucia: Mix it again
Tasha: 对搅拌到看不出一点粉
Tasha: Yeah, mix it until you can't see any powder
Lucia: 看不出一点粉
Lucia: Can't see any powder
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Tasha: 是这个意思吗
Tasha: Is that what you mean?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Hmm, yeah
Tasha: 旁边地上还有粉
Tasha: There's still powder on the floor
Tasha: 然后搅拌的再顺滑一点
Tasha: Then mix it until it's smoother
Lucia: 这个地方蹭的掉吗
Lucia: Can we scrub this off here?
Alice: 我要开始了
Alice: I'm going to start.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  热水烧好了耶
Katrina: The hot water is ready!
Tasha: 嗯差不多可以这样
Tasha: Hmm, this should be about right.
Tasha: 然后再把三个蛋黄加进去
Tasha: Then add the three egg yolks.
Tasha: 你要来抽蛋黄吗
Tasha: Do you want to separate the egg yolks?
Katrina:  嗯我要
Katrina: Yes, I do.
Alice: 哎我们家的油呢
Alice: Hey, where's our oil?
Tasha: 呃玉米油行吗
Tasha: Uh, is corn oil okay?
Tasha: 随便玉米油
Tasha: Any corn oil will do.
Katrina:  这是后来加了什么
Katrina: What did we add next?
Katrina:  然后变成坨坨了
Katrina: And then it turned lumpy.
Alice: 呃给我一点点点纸好吗
Alice: Uh, can you give me a bit of paper?
Lucia:啊是面粉吧
Lucia: Ah, it must be the flour.
Lucia: 我们加的
Lucia: We added it.
Lucia: OK牛奶加油加面
Lucia: Okay, milk, oil, and flour.
Tasha: OK可以了
Tasha: Okay, it's ready.
Tasha: 我看一下
Tasha: Let me take a look.
Tasha: 嗯可以了
Tasha: Hmm, it's done.
Tasha: 到你了呵呵呵呵
Tasha: It's your turn, hahaha.
Alice: 我们的葱姜蒜呢
Alice: Where's our garlic, ginger, and scallions?
Tasha: 葱姜蒜
Tasha: Garlic, ginger, scallions.
Alice: 这里边
Alice: In here.
Lucia: 在调料那一袋里面似乎
Lucia: Seems to be in the seasoning bag.
小薇 就在调料里面
Tasha: It's in the seasoning.
Katrina: 一个方向打就行
Katrina: Just stir in one direction.
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice: where where
Alice: Where, where?
Alice: 我尊嘟很急
Alice: I'm really anxious.
Tasha: 把它搅拌为你就融合在一起就行
Tasha: Just mix it until it's all combined.
Tasha: 你看现在没有融合对吧
Tasha: You see, it's not combined yet, right?
Alice: 嗯没有啊
Alice: Hmm, no, it's not.
Alice: 哦有
Alice: Oh, now it is.
Katrina:  好神奇哦
Katrina: It's so amazing.
Alice:好累啊
Alice: I'm so tired.
Alice: 我们那个现成的蒜呢
Alice: Where's our pre-chopped garlic?
Katrina:  现成的蒜
Katrina: Pre-chopped garlic?
Katrina:  冰箱里嗯
Katrina: It's in the fridge.
Alice: 现成的蒜
Alice: Pre-chopped garlic.
Alice: 是不是在那里边
Alice: Is it over there?
Tasha: 现成的蒜
Tasha: Ready-made garlic.
Tasha: 看一眼
Tasha: Let's take a look.
Tasha: 蒜蒜在这呀
Tasha: The garlic is right here.
Alice: 不是蒜苗蒜就那个白白胖胖的
Alice: Not the garlic sprouts, just the white and plump ones.
Alice: 嗯左左左左左上角
Alice: Hmm, to the left, to the left, top left.
Alice: 那那那给我一点就行了
Alice: That one, just give me a bit.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Alice: 拿出来就行
Alice: Just take it out.
Lucia: 给
Lucia: Here.
Tasha: 啊对
Tasha: Ah, right.
Tasha: good哈哈哈
Tasha: Good, haha.
Tasha: OK然后差不多有时间的话
Tasha: OK, if we have time...
Tasha: 我们可以把楼上的那个打蛋盆拿下来
Tasha: We can bring down the mixing bowl from upstairs.
Lucia: 啊看一眼
Lucia: Ah, let's take a look.
Lucia: 现在没关系
Lucia: It's fine for now.
Lucia: 好像还差几分钟
Lucia: Looks like a few more minutes.
Lucia: 三分钟
Lucia: Three minutes.
Tasha: 三分钟嗯
Tasha: Three minutes, yeah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 拿下来吧
Tasha: Let's bring it down.
Lucia: 可以啦 OK可以了没关系
Lucia: Sure, OK, it's fine.
Alice: 没有围裙对吧
Alice: We don't have aprons, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Alice: 好像没有就这吧
Alice: Seems like we don't, let's just use this.
Katrina:  接下来做什么
Katrina: What's next?
Tasha:接下来把蛋清
Tasha: Next, we separate the egg whites.
Tasha: 就是刚刚蛋黄和蛋清要分开
Tasha: We need to separate the yolks and whites.
Tasha: 分开之后他们现在先把蛋清打发一下
Tasha: After separating, we whip the egg whites.
Alice: 顺便帮我剥点蒜
Alice: By the way, help me peel some garlic.
Jake:现在在做什么
Jake: What are we doing now?
Lucia: 呃小蛋糕
Lucia: Uh, small cakes.
Alice: 哎有人 有手吗
Alice: Hey, does anyone have a hand free?
Katrina:  我帮你不
Katrina: Want me to help you?
Alice: 那个是密密封的
Alice: That one's sealed tight.
Alice: 我想等到你们那个火锅的时候再用
Alice: I want to use it when you guys have hot pot.
Katrina:  我帮你吧
Katrina: Let me help you.
Katrina:  好这个快结束了
Katrina: Alright, this is almost done.
Katrina:  就是把它
Katrina: Just need to...
Alice:: 啊这一点就行
Alice: Ah, this bit is enough.
Alice: 有点小不太好拨衣
Alice: It's a bit hard to peel.
Lucia: 来喽
Lucia: Coming over.
Tasha: 来喽来喽的话要放在这
Tasha: Coming over, we need to place it here.
Alice: 算了弄皮了
Alice: Forget it, let's just peel it.
Alice: 就这样吧反正洗过
Alice: It's fine, we've washed it anyway.
Katrina:  天呐AI在我这采集数据可杂了
Katrina: Oh my, the AI is collecting data from me so randomly.
Katrina:  一会干这一会干那
Katrina: Doing this and that every other moment.
Tasha: 然后能把白砂糖拿来吗
Tasha: Can you bring the white sugar?
Lucia: 白砂糖在
Lucia: The white sugar is...
Alice:这这呢
Alice: It's here.
Alice: 这个这个这个这个里面吧
Alice: This, this, this, put it inside here.
Lucia: 这里面
Lucia: Inside here?
Lucia: OK
Alice: OK.
Lucia: 哦这样
Lucia: Oh, like this.
Lucia: 哎这个白糖它可以撕开
Lucia: Hey, this white sugar can be torn open.
Lucia: 之后还能
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 那个拉链是吗
Lucia: Is it a zipper?
Lucia: 对哎呦好疼
Lucia: Yeah, ouch, that hurts.
Tasha: 纸杯蛋糕的纸杯
Tasha: The cupcake liners.
Alice: 假装没看到
Alice: Pretend you didn't see it.
Tasha: 好了吗嗯稍等
Tasha: Is it done? Hold on.
Tasha: 我拿个纸杯当个容器
Tasha: I'll use a cupcake liner as a container.
Tasha: 嗯哦  呵呵呵
Tasha: Hmm, oh, hehehe.
Tasha: 好放35克
Tasha: Alright, put 35 grams.
Lucia: 35克
Lucia: 35 grams?
Alice:: 我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice: 两个没事我点
Alice: It's fine, I'll just dot it.
Alice: 这蒜太小了不好剥
Alice: This garlic is too small to peel.
Tasha: 我天呐还有别的刀吗
Tasha: Oh my, is there another knife?
Alice: 有底下呢
Alice: Yes, it's down there.
Lucia: 嗯你看一眼
Lucia: Hmm, take a look.
Lucia: 这样可以吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Tasha:他倒了35克就行
Tasha: Yeah, as long as it's 35 grams.
Lucia: 倒了35.2吗
Lucia: Is 35.2 okay?
Tasha: 没关系待会用倒
Tasha: It's fine, we'll use it later.
Tasha: 哦不餐巾纸
Tasha: Oh no, not the napkin.
Tasha: 任何东西都不能沾水
Tasha: Nothing can get wet.
Alice: 难剥
Alice: Hard to peel.
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Lucia:然后我把这个白糖放到哎这上面
Lucia: Then I'll put this white sugar on top here.
Lucia: 好像已经放满了的样子
Lucia: It looks like it's already full.
Lucia: 管他呢给他挤一点位置出来
Lucia: Whatever, just make some room for it.
Tasha: 好然后
Tasha: Alright, then...
Tasha: 你看他现在是蛋清的样子对吧
Tasha: Look, it's like egg whites now, right?
Tasha: 嗯好然后这是35克
Tasha: Mm, okay, and this is 35 grams.
Tasha: 好这么多，这蒜真不好剥
Tasha: Okay, this much. This garlic is really hard to peel.
Tasha: 先低速再高速
Tasha: Start on low speed first, then high speed.
Tasha: 第一遍只要打出这种细
Tasha: The first time, just beat it until it's fine.
Alice: 你们是不是明天用火锅就行
Alice: Are you guys using the hotpot tomorrow?
Katrina:  应该是明天晚上吧
Katrina: I think it's for tomorrow night.
Alice: 受不了了我要用那个蒜了
Alice: I can't wait, I need to use that garlic.
Katrina:  要等他回来才
Katrina: Have to wait for him to come back first.
Tasha: 呃再帮我取5克玉米淀粉吧
Tasha: Uh, can you get me 5 grams of corn starch?
Lucia: 呃15克
Lucia: Uh, 15 grams?
Lucia: 5克呃
Lucia: 5 grams, uh...
Lucia: 5克
Lucia: 5 grams.
Tasha: 用这个用这个取
Tasha: Use this, use this to measure.
Lucia: 这个就先拿下来
Lucia: Let's take this out first.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah...
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  还要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Do we need to add lemon too?
Tasha:加过了
Tasha: Already added.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  为什么要加柠檬啊
Katrina: Why do we need to add lemon?
Tasha: 去腥
Tasha: To remove the fishy smell.
Katrina:  哦哈哈
Katrina: Oh, haha.
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
小薇 嗯对对对5克就行
Tasha: Yes, yes, yes, 5 grams is enough.
Tasha: 然后第二遍是这个状态就行
Tasha: Then the second time, just like this.
Lucia: 哇嗯
Lucia: Wow, um.
Tasha: 然后最后一遍
Tasha: And then the last time...
Lucia: 好神奇蛋清竟然会打成这样
Lucia: It's amazing how egg whites can turn into this.
Lucia: 等一下这个要把它再清理一下吗
Lucia: Wait, do we need to clean this again?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Tasha: 5克
Tasha: 5 grams.
Tasha: 可以可以好给我吧
Tasha: Okay, okay, give it to me.
Alice: 好我们是没有汤勺
Alice: Alright, do we not have a soup ladle?
Alice: 应该有吧
Alice: We should have one, right?
Alice: 没有汤勺
Alice: No soup ladle.
Alice: 在后面
Alice: It's in the back.
Lucia: 汤勺我好像也没看见
Lucia: I can't find the soup spoon either.
Lucia: 看他们这有没有
Lucia: Let's see if they have it here.
Lucia: 是卖的哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh, they sell it, haha.
Lucia: 这样先晃一下吧
Lucia: Let's just shake it for now.
Tasha: 希望他不会拒绝吧
Tasha: Hope he won't refuse.
Katrina:  爱上了打蛋
Katrina: Fell in love with whisking.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Tasha: 打发成这样子能提起来
Tasha: Whip it until it can stand up like this.
Tasha: 然后他不会
Tasha: And then it won't...
Tasha: 他你看他这个有个尖尖
Tasha: Look, there's a little peak.
Tasha: 他不会掉下来就说明就打完了
Tasha: It won't fall down, that means it's done.
Alice: 一步是要把水锅里的水给蒸发一下
Alice: One step is to evaporate the water in the pot.
Alice: 不然他会怎么样
Alice: Otherwise, what will happen?
Tasha: 就是一个废气
Tasha: Just a waste of gas.
Alice: 他会啪啦啪啦的
Alice: It'll go pop, pop.
Alice: 就是水跟油不香
Alice: Water and oil don't smell good together.
Alice: 他们不是好朋友
Alice: They aren't good friends.
Alice: 他们会打架
Alice: They'll fight.
Alice: 居然是玉米油
Alice: It's actually corn oil.
Katrina:  我们俩特别像学生
Katrina: We look just like students.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  这老师在干什么
Katrina: What's the teacher doing?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 然后有种接受培训的感觉
Lucia: It feels like we're getting trained.
Katrina:  我们在新东方啊
Katrina: We're at New Oriental, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, exactly.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 把这个分三次划进去
Tasha: Divide this into three parts.
Tasha: 第一遍的话就只有分三遍刮
Tasha: The first time, you should scrape it three times.
Tasha: 他才会充分融合
Tasha: Then it will fully blend.
Tasha: 第一遍的话他不是会很充分
Tasha: The first time, it won't blend completely.
Tasha: 你可能觉得他充分了
Tasha: You might think it has,
Tasha: 但其实没那么充分
Tasha: but it hasn't fully blended.
Katrina:  这个白色的就是刚刚蛋清加了什么的
Katrina: This white stuff, it's the egg white with what?
Tasha: 蛋清加了糖啊
Tasha: Egg white with sugar.
Katrina:  蛋清加了糖就变成这样了对
Katrina: So, egg white with sugar turns out like this, right?
Katrina:  蛋清刚刚不是液体吗
Katrina: The egg white was liquid before,
Katrina:  现在怎么变成橡皮体
Katrina: so how did it turn into rubber?
Katrina:  嗯因为那个机器打就是啊
Katrina: Yeah, because that machine works like...
Katrina:  然后他就会起泡
Katrina: It starts to foam up.
Lucia: 对好神奇的哦 哈哈哈
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing! Hahaha
Katrina:  amazing
Katrina: Amazing
Katrina:  蛋清加了蛋清
Katrina: Added egg whites
Tasha: 然后加第二次进去
Tasha: Then add the second time
Alice: 其实我放错顺序
Alice: Actually, I put it in the wrong order
Alice: 我应该先放皮蛋的
Alice: I should have added the century egg first
Tasha: 嗯我觉得应该先把烤箱预热
Tasha: Hmm, I think we should preheat the oven first
Lucia: 要预热一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to preheat it?
Lucia: 等一下
Lucia: Wait a second
Tasha: 热水在吗
Tasha: Is the hot water there?
Tasha: 在
Tasha: Yes
Tasha: 有点水没关系哦
Tasha: A little water is fine
Lucia: 要擦一下吗
Lucia: Should we wipe it?
Tasha: 哦可以擦一下
Tasha: Oh, you can wipe it
Tasha: 哦谢谢
Tasha: Oh, thank you
Tasha: 哦对然后我们把这个第二个
Tasha: Oh right, then we put this second one
Alice: 粘锅了
Alice: Stuck to the pan
Alice: 哦啊
Alice: Oh no
Tasha: 预热一下的
Tasha: Preheat it
Tasha: 话烤箱里的温度更好
Tasha: So the temperature in the oven is better
Lucia: OK啊边上这个也擦一下吧
Lucia: OK, can you also wipe the side here?
Tasha: 看其实你以为很融合
Tasha: See, you think it's well mixed
Tasha: 但其实还是没那么融合
Tasha: But actually it's not that well mixed
Tasha: 所以就是要分三遍
Tasha: So you have to do it three times
Lucia:要分次
Lucia: Do it in parts
Tasha: 对然后你可以把纸杯蛋糕放上去
Tasha: Yes, then you can put the cupcakes in
Lucia: 放到这个
Lucia: Put it here
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes
Lucia:托盘上
Lucia: On the tray
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes
Katrina:  然后排起开烤
Katrina: Then line them up and start baking
Tasha: 这就是我们的蛋糕胚部分就完成了
Tasha: This completes the cake base part
Katrina:  哦然后就把它舀进去就好了
Katrina: Oh, then just scoop it in
Lucia:哦原来蛋糕胚是这样做的
Lucia: Oh, so that's how cake bases are made
Lucia: 6个我们这个需要几个
Lucia: We need six, how many do we need?
Katrina:  大概能装多少个
Katrina: About how many can we make?
Tasha: 呃这个
Tasha: Uh, this
Tasha: 哈哈哈 好
Tasha: Hahaha, okay
Katrina: 装了再说吧
Katrina: Let's fill it up and see
Tasha: 就就这样放着吧
Tasha: Just leave it like that
Lucia: 行呃
Lucia: Okay, uh
Tasha: 不太能确定
Tasha: I'm not really sure
Lucia: 没事装完要是不够
Lucia: It's fine, if it's not enough
Lucia: 我们再拿出几个杯子
Lucia: We can get a few more cups
Tasha: 可以放到这个里面
Tasha: We can pour it into this
Tasha: 因为这个有个嘴
Tasha: Because this one has a spout
Tasha: 他好倒啊
Tasha: It's easy to pour
Tasha: OK
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 所以这个杯子他既可以倒嘴
Tasha: So this cup can be used to pour
Tasha: 然后呢他还有容容量
Tasha: And it has a good capacity
Katrina:  这个叫什么
Katrina: What's this called?
Tasha: 呃叫鸟嘴杯
Tasha: Uh, it's called a bird beak cup
Tasha: 鸟嘴杯只要做烘焙都会买的
Tasha: Anyone who bakes would buy this bird beak cup
Tasha: 好了然后就就倒就行了
Tasha: Alright, just pour it in
Tasha: 大家可以都试试
Tasha: Everyone can try it
Tasha: 倒到差不多这里
Tasha: Pour it to about here
Tasha: 因为它会膨膨胀起来嘛
Tasha: Because it will expand
Lucia: 哦嗯
Lucia: Oh, got it
Lucia: 咦你先来啊
Lucia: Hey, you go first
Katrina:  好你先打样
Katrina: Okay, you go first
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 我们学习一下如何倒
Lucia: Let's learn how to pour it
Katrina:  啊差不多这么多就行啊
Katrina: Ah, about this much is fine, right?
Lucia: 来慢慢了解啊
Lucia: Let's take it slow
Lucia: 我试一下谢谢
Lucia: I'll give it a try, thanks
Tasha: 好了好
Tasha: Alright
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one
Tasha: 挪果断的挪没关系哈哈
Tasha: Move decisively, it's okay, haha
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Katrina:  可以好像可以再倒一点什么
Katrina: You can pour a little more
Lucia: 姐妹你来
Lucia: Sister, you go
Lucia: 他好像滴出来了一点点
Lucia: It seems like it dripped a little
Tasha:没关系没关系
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay
Lucia: 在边上没事吧
Lucia: It's fine on the side, right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 继续倒吧
Tasha: Keep pouring
Lucia: 对可以再倒一点
Lucia: Yes, pour a little more
Lucia: 感觉好像没有特别多
Lucia: It doesn't seem like there's much
Katrina:  差不多了
Katrina: Almost done
Katrina:  好，给我吧
Katrina: Okay, give it to me
Lucia: 是不是挨近一点
Lucia: Should we get a bit closer?
Tasha: 瓜瓜还能再来一杯
Tasha: Gua Gua, can we have another drink?
Lucia: 呃再放一个杯子啊
Lucia: Uh, should we get another cup?
Katrina:  不用啊
Katrina: No need.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: OK最后我一共烤了10个嗯哼
Tasha: OK, so I baked a total of 10, uh-huh.
Tasha: 然后我们送入烤箱就可以
Tasha: And then we can put them in the oven.
Lucia: 要按一下哪里
Lucia: Where do I need to press?
Lucia: 哦那让他
Lucia: Oh, let him do it.
Lucia: 那个表为什么又倒了
Lucia: Why did the timer reset again?
Tasha: 哦你看它这温度其实不准
Tasha: Oh, you see, the temperature is actually inaccurate.
Tasha: 烤箱温度显示它已经
Tasha: The oven temperature shows it's already...
Katrina:  哇好可爱
Katrina: Wow, so cute!
Alice: 感觉好像坏掉了
Alice: Feels like it's broken.
Alice: 算了不放它
Alice: Forget it, don't put it in.
Katrina:  这大概烤多久啊
Katrina: How long does this need to bake?
Tasha: 呃50分钟
Tasha: Uh, 50 minutes.
Tasha: 正好吃饭吃完饭吧
Tasha: Just right, we can have it after dinner.
Tasha: 行了
Tasha: Done.
Tasha: 第一次是口烤20分钟
Tasha: The first time, bake it for 20 minutes.
Katrina:  啊分分次的
Katrina: Ah, in intervals.
Tasha: 对他先低温烤熟
Tasha: Yes, bake it at a low temperature first.
Tasha: 然后高温上色啊
Tasha: Then raise the temperature to get the color.
Katrina:  好好玩
Katrina: So fun!
Tasha: 他如果盯了之后
Tasha: If it's done and I'm not here...
Tasha: 我如果不在的话就是他这个时间到了
Tasha: If I'm not around, it will be done in 20 minutes.
Tasha: 20分钟就到了
Tasha: 20 minutes will be up.
Tasha: 嗯然后你把这个上火调成130
Tasha: Then you set the top heat to 130.
Tasha: 下火也调成130
Tasha: Bottom heat also to 130.
Tasha: 再打30分钟
Tasha: Bake for another 30 minutes.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Lucia: OK 13013030我要去上厕所
Lucia: OK, 130, 130, 30, I need to go to the bathroom.
Tasha: yes然后我们要把残垃圾清理掉
Tasha: Yes, and we need to clean up the leftover trash.
Tasha: 尤其是这个盆
Tasha: Especially this bowl.
Tasha: 因为等会咱们还得再打奶油
Tasha: Because we're going to whip the cream with it later.
Tasha: 也是用它的
Tasha: We’ll use it again.
Lucia: OK OK这些这些纸就先先扔了吧
Lucia: OK, OK, let's throw away these papers first.
Tasha: 对全部都扔掉
Tasha: Yes, throw everything away.
Tasha: 这个是洗一下
Tasha: This one needs to be washed.
Tasha: 然后全部都洗
Tasha: Then wash everything.
Tasha: 然后擦干
Tasha: Then wipe it dry.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK OK.
Lucia: 这个哎
Lucia: This one, hey.
Lucia: 那我就把这个菜先拿出来
Lucia: I'll take this dish out first.
Lucia: 菜放这就会
Lucia: I'll put the dish here.
Lucia: 嗯这边水倒掉一点吧
Lucia: Hmm, let's pour out some of this water.
Tasha: 对我把垃圾收一下
Tasha: Yeah, I'll take care of the trash.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Tasha: 这些都是要洗的
Tasha: All of these need to be washed.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Got it.
Alice: 白菜呢嗯
Alice: Where's the cabbage, hmm?
Lucia: 在这里我害怕洗那个什么
Lucia: Here, I was scared to wash it.
Lucia: 洗到里面我就把它拿出来了
Lucia: I took it out before washing it too much.
Alice: 涮一下这个
Alice: Rinse this one.
Lucia: 呃咱这应该有抹布吧
Lucia: Uh, we should have a cloth here, right?
Tasha: 有吧
Tasha: I think so.
Lucia: 没有的话
Lucia: If not...
Lucia: 哎呀那个那个那个海绵有点脏
Lucia: Oh, that sponge is a bit dirty.
Lucia: 不是很想用啊
Lucia: I don't really want to use it.
Lucia: 这还有一个
Lucia: There's another one here.
Lucia: 这给他扔过去哎
Lucia: I'll throw this one over there, hey.